hey guys I'm here with Josh from 343
industries just here two awesome
questions about hey loophole so hey
lefrozer sodomy new trilogy if this
trilogy goes well are there any plans to
make more games afterwards so I I mean
we really think of of Halo as a saga you
know an enduring saga that can continue
in a universe full of possibility so
with Halo 4 we're really kind of setting
the stage for number one the next
chapter obviously with this game but but
you know also future stories and and so
there there are some some stakes that we
put in the ground and some ideas about
where we're taking the universe and you
know course that'll that'll grow and
change over time but as far as yet can
you expect future Halo games absolutely
hey here I think I think that that's
definitely something we expect what was
your favorite part of making halo I
think my favorite part of making the
game is just the the experience of
having this amazing team come together
and and and build this massive game as a
unit and anytime you have creative
passionate people who share the same
kind of vision it's just a magical
feeling and and I think the the process
of bringing together 300 plus people
around such a mammoth scale project is
has been really challenging at times but
it's really really rewarding especially
now that we have the game essentially
done and we can look at what we
what we've managed to achieve and how
has master chief himself evolved as a
character so a big focus for us with the
master chieftain telling his story was
to try and delve a little deeper into
him as a character if you look at the
past halo games chief has been you know
not really explored too deeply but in
the surrounding fiction there's a lot
more information around his backstory
and and a little bit more about you know
who he is as a human being and we wanted
to bring that more to the forefront in
the game and sort of put him in in
situations that would challenge who who
he is and and make you know sort of
force him to make tough decisions so I
mean you can expect to see chief grow
and change in ways that he hasn't been
in past Halo games which which is pretty
exciting so it's sort of a goal for 343
to make the chief more of a person than
a player I think a little bit you know
it's always hard because with chief he's
such a stoic and reserved character he's
not he's not the most expressive person
and we're not trying to change that
we're not turning him into you know a
weepy emo character that blathers on all
the time he's still very stoic he's he's
still very controlled but there are
aspects of his character that we're
trying to bring a little bit more to the
surface and then really exploring his
relationship with Cortana